on peut trouver de l'or noir dans les
yvelines le comptoir du caviar basé dans
la petite commune de 1100 a pour fond de
commerce et e d'esturgeons l'atelier qui
emploie une quinzaine de personnes est
installée dans le département depuis 30
ans et j'y vais parce que le fondateur
du comptoir du caviar qui a donc cédé
son affaire était un parisien qui s'est
installée là parce qu'il aimait beaucoup
la région
et voilà donc ils ont aidés notamment au
golf et c'est un environnement tout à
fait exceptionnelle pour pour travailler
avant d'atterrir à 1100 l'objectif de
l'entreprise est de sélectionner les
meilleurs caviars du monde
pour cela les responsables travaille
essentiellement avec des fermes
françaises et d'europe de l'est
le produit est ensuite envoyée dans les
yvelines pour être affinée et
conditionné temps entre le moment de la
pêche et son optimum on va dire de
maturité de goût en général on compte
six mois et le cas bien évolué mais il
va falloir le surveiller dans ces boîtes
dont on surveille avec attention les
boîtes on les retourne on enlève leur
éventuellement que cette voie là on les
gouttes régulièrement en finale un
caviar à parfaite maturité
la société produit également dans ses
700 m² du tarama fait à base d'oeufs de
cabillaud en ce moment pour les fêtes la
production a doublé
dix mille verrines sont produites chaque
jour ce qui en fait l'un des
best-sellers de la maison on n'a jamais
vendu autant tarama notamment au moment
du confinement parce que c'est un
produit très festive très plaisir une
trop gourmand et les ventes finalement
se sont envolées donc
donc ça c'est vraiment un produit qui
fonctionne très bien et une époque
saisonniers une fois après une partie
des produits ensuite vendus dans cette
boutique parisienne située boulevard
malesherbes il vitrine pour la marque
ouverte depuis 2016 l'objectif ici de
démocratiser le caviar en racontant son
histoire
quand vous allez pouvoir retrouver sur
notre mur derrière on explique ba trois
espèces principales avec lesquels on
travaille comment ça se passe ça se
passe aussi par le fait qu'on propose
aussi systématiquement une dégustation
de nos produits pour que les gens
si voilà puisse et avoir des
explications mais aussi l'expérience en
même temps le caviar de la marque se
retrouve également dans les épiceries
fines dans les grands hôtels et
restaurants français à l'étranger
si vous voulez tester le premier prix
est à 23 euros les 20 g